let's go to Amos from Kansas Amos from
Kansas City Welcome to the program
what's on your mind today
hi David I'm a long time listener long
time supporter of you and I'm happy to
be on here first time I've ever gotten
on but uh I first had a question but I
wanted to answer one of your questions
that you asked a couple of weeks ago but
Jordan bobert loves to say those words
pleading the blood of Jesus yeah I was
born and raised Apostolic Pentecostal so
I could tell you what that means please
what does it mean it's kind of a legal
term
but in the way that like Jesus died for
you because and that blood that he
spilled was a covenant between God and
man and so when things go wrong we plead
the blood of the Covenant
and who do you plead who do you plead to
God himself God the father because the
Covenant is Jesus Christ's blood and
he's that's and yeah that's the best way
I can explain it but that's how it's
explained to me at growing up and what
are you pleading for
it depends on the situation like I guess
foreign bobert's situation it would be
pleading the blood out for you know
making Trump president or something like
that so if I understand correctly you
would plead the blood of Jesus to God in
order to achieve something that you want
yes pretty much okay all right very good
I understand that that's just my
explanation for it but anyway uh my
question for you has to do with I I'm a
big follower of a guy named Hemet Metta
and he did a uh uh poll and he's like
you he gets these a plus rated polls and
stuff but he did it on the the religions
of the world that are best seen most
positively and most negatively okay and
I wanted to to know your opinion on this
because it according to the poll Mormons
are the most are the least
positively viewed religion however even
though it doesn't seem like it based
upon the I don't know the loudness of
the minorities
it Jews are the most positively seen
according to his pose yeah so so let's
let's be clear the poll you're referring
to is a Pew Research Center poll so I
think it's important when we say his
poll I follow Hemet on on Twitter it's a
Pew Research Center poll so quite uh
quite quite reputable
um so the uh this is only among
Americans I think it's important to
mention that's one thing this these are
not Global views about these different
religions and you're absolutely right
among Americans
Jews followed by uh let's well see it's
kind of complicated because of how this
is ranked Jews almost perfectly followed
by Catholics then Mainline Protestants
then Evangelical Christians then
atheists Muslims and Mormons in that
order are seen as most favorable to sort
of like least favorable
um the difficulty about that poll is
it's all kind of low numbers like the
difference between the least favorable
which is Mormons and Jews which is the
most favorable is only 20 points it's 15
to 35. so I I have a couple different
thoughts on this number one
um the U.S
has a a different sort of perspective on
a lot of these religions than the world
so like I think that Mormonism might be
seen differently in other parts of the
world where the like the population of
Mormons is very different I mean it's a
very interesting poll I don't really
know what to make of it I do think that
when it comes to Jews some of the
favorable is probably based in
anti-semitic tropes like people who are
like oh yeah Jews control some great
Industries so like I see them favorably
in that way but it doesn't necessarily
mean that like you necessarily think
Jews are good people or whatever you
know what I'm saying right right but it
is a very interesting poll yeah I I you
know the other thing about it is the
vast majority of respondents have no
opinion about most of those religions
like 60 of the respondents said I don't
have any I don't know enough about Jews
to say one way or the other
well if if it's any consolation I view
all all Jews to be the you know my my uh
mother's side of the family is a lot of
there's a lot of that is Jewish okay but
anyway thank you very much all right
yeah very interesting Paul thanks for
bringing it up I do appreciate that